bonjour à tous du coup aujourd'hui s'il
est le pay day 2018 on est le 3 le 14
c'est le 14 mars 2018 et j'étais invité
à donner une présentation ici au 31 ans
est intégré sur causeur sert alors de
les mathématiciens préféré s'arrêter
trop génial puis avoir plein
d'exposition à l'intérieur donc à
l'excès la petite intro et durera
quelques images et après il y aura à ma
conférence
[Musique]
on
bonjour à tous alors je suis très honoré
on sens très privilégié d'être ici pour
parler au panthéon de l'un de mes
personnages historiques est le préféré
du marquis de condorcet donc sans je
vais vous parler aujourd'hui en
particulier c'est ce qui est je pense
voilà la pluie ne plus grande idée de
condorcet mais je pense même l'une des
plus grandes idées que quiconque ait
jamais eu dans l'histoire du vide et
puis klose et ce dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui c'est arithmétique
politique c'est le terme qui a utilisé
condorcet c'est cette idée selon
laquelle les mathématiques
d'habitude je pense qu'à l'école on a
tendance à penser que les mathématiques
sont très loin d'un côté ensuite il ya
pas quelque chose comme les sciences
physiques et les sciences et puis tout
au bout on attend ça m la sociologie la
politique ou la philosophie
eh bien je pense que l'une des plus
grandes idées condorcet c'est de se dire
en fait non même ces questions qui
paraît si distants des mathématiques etc
ont pris consciemment aujourd'hui en
fait il ya certaines de ces questions au
moins ils gagnent à être mathématisée et
je pense que c'est vraiment l'une de
plus grandes idées de condorcet et en
particulier d'avoir appliqué sa théorie
des scrutins je pense qu'il a vraiment
initié tout un tout un domaine en fait
les mathématiques appliquées appliquée à
autre chose question de la nature
notamment et pose pas le seul ans il y
en a d'autres mais je pense que c'est
vraiment des 1
une des grandes figures de ce mouvement
et à titre personnel bien sûr ça m'a pas
mal touché puisque je me suis mis à
faire de la recherche
j'ai trouvé ces idées vraiment
inspirante et du coup je me suis mis à
faire des recherches dans ces domaines
et pendant mes années de recherche
notamment thèse j'ai vraiment eu
l'impression que condorcet m'avaient
accompagné dans mes idées du coup j'ai
quasiment après avoir une relation
intime avec condensé et j'ai des
fantasmes comme ça à mes fantasmes
toujours interdit aux histoires des
sciences et c'est devoir parler à des
mathématiciens du passé et leur dire à
dire félicitations
ce que j'ai fait c'est rempli et
également pour la leur dire jusqu'où
leurs idées peuvent tout à l'est et dans
le cas de condorcet je pense qu'il
aurait été absolument ravis et très
enthousiaste à l'idée de la tuerie des
scrutins qui a été développé lui aussi
avec la produit et en particulier
j'aimerais vraiment lui parler du
littoral basque du scrutin de condenser
vandalisé les chances qu'il serait
vraiment ravi voilà donc d'une certaine
manière on est juste en étant ici au
panthéon avec condorcet enterré ben j'ai
l'impression de réaliser son fantasme le
persil ou cloud sommes donc qu'on dort
scène il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
sur conversait avant de parler du
scrutin de commencer on va en parler
j'aimerais revenir un peu sur l'homme et
toute son oeuvre parce que condorcet
c'est bien plus qu'un mathématicien et
s'est intéressée à bruz de beaucoup
beaucoup de choses pour planter le décor
donc on a au xviiie siècle c'est
l'époque de l'ancien régime avec les
fameux trois ordres et à cette époque là
il ya de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont sensibles aux inégalités dans la
société et on les appelle les
philosophes des lumières ils remettent
en cause ce statut cet ordre social et
ce qui est particulier avec condorcet
qui est clairement l'un d'eux s'est
close up des lumières c'est qu' il va
être sensible à toutes les formes
d'inégalités quand on pense à la
révolution française on pense beaucoup
aux inégalités de classe sociale
mais même après la révolution française
beaucoup d'intellectuels vont défendre
par exemple le droit de vote univers 506
terre souvent plutôt qu'universelle mais
pour les hommes
en fait on m'a dit donc là un ami
historien du xviiie siècle qui m'a dit
qu'en fait en défendant la cause des
femmes
avec cet article de 1791 notamment
condorcet pour s'être passé pour un ovni
pascal assez étonnante et si vous allez
sur la page wikipedia partante du
féminisme vous verrez que condorcet les
cités et c'est vraiment un mouvement
incroyable
enfin ça c'était très osée et très
impopulaire que de défendre la cause des
femmes à cette époque qu'on danse est
aussi très sensible à toutes les formes
d inégalités dans la société envers les
protestants envers les juifs il va aussi
écrire sur l' esclavage les noirs dans
les colonies françaises
et lorsqu'un nationale intéressant si
dans cet article dans ce texte et qui va
passer ou pas il va pas juste dire que
c'est mal parce que à cette époque-là
choisir c'est à cette époque là on est
pas une époque d'abondance comme on a
aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui ont enfin
il ya la famille d'encore les gens ont
vraiment peur que
keane est en crise économique et du coup
abolir l'esclavagé
ça semble être un quasiment en suicide
de civils de la civilisation en tout cas
tel que ces dits par beaucoup condorcet
va avoir une vision progressiste désire
en effet peut-être que à bouillir du
jour au lendemain les slaves âge ça va
poser vraiment des problèmes mais si on
essaie de ce devoir dans sur le long
terme
le temps et si on essaie de prendre en
compte les progrès des technologies
notamment il va écrire en 1795
c'est sa dernière oeuvre publiée à titre
posthume
quelque chose sur les progrès
technologiques il va se dire que grâce
aux progrès technologiques qui se
rassemblent possible de produire des
biens ont suffisamment de biens sans
avoir à recourir à l esclavage
je pense que c'est une vision de la
société la prise en compte de ces
technologies c'est quelque chose de très
intelligent ne peuvent en tout cas c'est
une très belle réflexion de converser
[Musique]
condensé va s'intéresser vraiment à tout
faire ce genre de choses ainsi c'est
vraiment un primate il va s'intéresser à
l'économie à l'époque ou encore
l'économie étudie la production des
biens et c'est pas forcément un truc
d'intellectuels a priori à cette époque
pour ça commence à le devenir mais c'est
encore plus du tout nouveau conseil va
écrire sur la liberté de la presse et
condorcet va aussi pourquoi écrire sur
la physique c'est tout de l'époque aussi
notamment sur le fameux problème des
trois corps qui est un peu le
l'hypothèse de riemann de l'époque c'est
vraiment le grand la grande question de
l'époque mais condorcet c'est aussi a
bien sûr un mathématicien ça que j'en
parle aujourd'hui et notamment il aura
début de sa carrière beaucoup étudié
l'analyse parce que c'est vraiment ce
que tous les mathématiciens faisait à
l'époque c'était un peu c'est un peu
d'intelligence artificielle de l'époque
s'intéressait à ce sujet et quand il va
contribuer également à ces domaines mais
il va aussi s'intéresser à la théorie
des probabilités des statistiques qui
est un domaine très balbutiante évoque
là c'est encore tout nouveau saisi les
théories sont pas encore tous se prouver
enfin séparant le de thuram centrale
limite à qui est très bien
très bien imaginer ici au panthéon c1
n'a pas encore été prouvé que les gens
pensent avoir l'intuition et commence à
voir des cas particuliers mais rien il
ya beaucoup de travail à faire et ce qui
est intéressant avec cette théorie des
probabilités des statistiques c'est que
ça permet de sortir du cadre habituel
c'est-à-dire que ont veillé équation
différentielle des études de cours de
l'analyse cc c'est vraiment des maths
pour la physique à la base
alors que là on a des maths qui sont
peut-être pas les maths à cette citation
de galilée qui dit que l'étude des
mathématiques les mathématiques c'est le
langage de la nature et peut-être ma
tendance à penser du coup que les maths
sont surtout appliqués à la physique
votre cas condorcet va sortir vraiment
déçu de ce cadre de conseil va il va
vraiment on en parlait de l'arithmétique
politique et désire que cet outil
mathématique cela rigueur la puissance
et la précision du langage mathématique
peuvent aussi avoir beaucoup d'humilité
dans les réflexions sur des sujets aussi
a priori floue et ambiguë que la
politique voilà donc ça c'est un peu la
longue introduction sur la vie et
l'oeuvre de condorcet maintenant on va
parler en particulier de la théorie des
scrutins qui qui est l'écran de
réflexion de yoga condorcet aussi voir
quand on parle de scrutin d'habitude on
pense politique l'expérience qu'on a il
est vrai je parle du scrutin les gens
sont tout de suite
le gouvernement le pouvoir le
gouvernement et les méchantes alors que
en fait non là le problème des scrutins
c'est un peu beaucoup plus générale que
ça fait c'est le problème de la prise de
décision collective et ça c'est un
problème que l'on rencontre tout temps
si vous voulez aller voir un film entre
amis ou aller au restaurant entre amis
vous devez choisir un restaurant ou un
film et il ya un problème de prise de
décisions collectifs neufs au point une
bonne une décision qui sera valable pour
tout le groupe
et ça c'est intéressant de se demander
comment est ce qu'on prend ses décisions
en pratique je sais pas vous mais
souvent il ya ces on a un petit groupe
d'amis je pense qu'il ya à peu près deux
façons un peu extrême de prendre ce
genre de décision d'un côté il ya ce que
je vais appeler l' autoritarisme il ya
un mec qui décide toujours un peu chiant
mais il décide et de l'autre côté il ya
ce que je vais appeler le pseudo
consensus
le pseudo consensus c'est trois amis
sympa on s'aime bien du coup on veut que
tout soit content quelqu'un dans une
idée quand il y en a un qui pas content
il ya un autre qui lance une idée les
deux autres sont pas contents et ça
continue ça continue et d'un moment il
ya une idée qui va être lancé et plus
personne va se plaindre c'est à dire
qu'ils sont tous d'accord c'est à dire
qu'ils sont morts dont ils ont envie de
manger des choses comme ça et la
décision devait être arrêté et je pense
que la plupart des décisions c'est
quelque chose entre ces deux en tout cas
de façon informelle
le problème de ces prises de décision
c'est bon il a pas mal mais un des
problèmes c'est que c'est pas des
décisions égalitaire c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas tous le même pouvoir d'un
finances sur la décision finale
dans le cas de l'autoritarisme espère ne
pas avoir besoin de faire de preuve
mathématique
dans le cas du pseudo consensus en fait
en pratique il ya des gens qui râlent
plus c'est des gens qui disent qu'ils
parlent plus qu'ils ont plus de charisme
plus influencent ils vont avoir du coup
plus d' influence sur la prise de
décision finale
et du coup d'une certaine manière la
prise de décisions par pseudo consensus
discrimine les personnes introverties ou
ceux qui qui aime pas se plaindre par
exemple et du coup c'est un problème pas
si évident que la prise de décision
cole et de collectifs égalitaire et
c'est à cette question que répond le
point que la solution des scrutins les
scrutins c'est une façon de garantir le
fait que chacun n'aura qu'une voix et
pas plus et chacun aura la même voie
d'une certaine manière c'est une
question assez un terrain de dire en
fait il existe une solution à ce
problème c'est pas si évident de si vous
y réfléchissez
par exemple on peut une variante ce qui
serait le vote à main levée le vote à
main levée on peut se dire que chacun a
vraiment une voix mais en fait c'est pas
tout à fait vrai l'imaginer mais entre
nous peut-être sans doute que ce sera le
cas mais imaginez que ce soit un conseil
d'administration de l'entreprise et il
ya beaucoup de beaucoup beaucoup d'enjeu
beaucoup d'intérêts individuels et
chacun le fait que le vote soit public
fait qui peut avoir des débats des jeux
de pouvoir d des coalitions qui se forme
voire des menaces et des fous dangereux
d'une certaine heure en rendant le vote
public ont restreint indirectement le
pouvoir d'expression de la liberté
d'expression au moment du vote de
certains et le fait qu'il existe ça
sauver cette solution advanced quasiment
quelque chose de très lourd du très très
c'est une belle solution technologique
mais on peut se demander si point
saccucci enfin ça coûte beaucoup de
temps comme on peut pas prendre toutes
nos décisions politiques dans une
société comme la france au scrutin parce
que ça ça prend toute une journée
ça ça prend beaucoup de temps tout ça du
coup on peut se demander est ce qu'il
serait possible d'avoir toutes ces
bonnes propriétés du scrutin le fait
même temps qu'ils soient anonymes et
vérifiable mais sans toute la complexité
d'une journée d'élection ce qui serait
possible de rendre ce vote électronique
par exemple avec en gardant tout les
problèmes propriété ça c'est une grande
question de recherche actuellement
typiquement sas et l'arithmétique
politique de force elle s'applique
jusque là
envie de faire une autre réflexion qui
ont envie de pousser aussi par rapport à
ça c'est cette idée d'égalité
je pense que lorsqu'on pense égalité on
pense à égalité au moment du vote
une personne une voix si on en a parlé
je pense qu'une autre forme d'égalité
dont on a un sentiment rapidement en
tête c'est l'égalité devant la loi
c'est aussi une question qui est pas si
facile je pense que j'en parle parce que
voilà d'une certaine heure j'ai
l'impression de parler un petit peu a
condensé et je pense qu'il serait
fasciné par ses idées si on pense au
vote à l'égalité devant la loi de l'eau
problème c'est que la loi est vraiment
été très générale elle s'applique jamais
vraiment un cas particulier du coup
qu'est ce qu'on fait nous dans nos
sociétés c'est qu'on introduit un humain
un juge ou des jurés qui vont adapter la
loi au cas particulier et le problème
avec ça c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
recherches en psychologie qui montrent
en fait on a tous ici même tous présents
désolé de vous l'annoncer mais moi
compris on a tous pleins de billets
inconscient pour l'udc ont même si on se
pense pas du tout sexy c'est pas du tout
raciste pas du tout ce que vous voulez
inconsciemment on va prendre des
décisions qui vont être biaisé d'un côté
ou de l'autre
et du coup on fait l'égalité devant la
loi
pacy pas si évident qu'elle soit
vraiment vérifié et en fait aujourd'hui
il ya énormément de recherche justement
sur comment remplacer cette prise de
décision
pendant que sur les jugent encore une
fois il ya des études qui montrent que
des juges qui ont faim sont beaucoup
plus sévères mais alors beaucoup
beaucoup plus sévère c'est ça c'est chou
et du coup il ya une discrimination par
la justice en fonction de l'heure à
laquelle vous allez être jugé et du coup
on peut se poser la question mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas avoir un système
notamment avec des algorithmes qui
ferait des décisions qui sont vraiment
pas blessé si l'objectif est de ne pas
avoir de billet de biais peut-être qu'on
peut corriger les biens les algorithmes
et ça c'est de la recherche actuelle
ceci n'est normes un homme fort de
recherche actuels notamment la question
de casque un billet kss kss kss kss
qu'une décision raciste ou sexiste
c'est une question qui traînent on trial
un tel point qu'il ya des dizaines de
papiers qui devait publier tous les ans
sur ce sujet c'est une brune genre de
questions fascinantes et je pense que
condorcet ont été absolument fasciné par
ces questions ouais pour l'umq d
expression on revient au scrutin donc je
vais donner un petit exemple imaginons
que nous tout ça demain nous devions
aller visiter un musée et on a le choix
entre ces trois options le palais de la
découverte
la cité des sciences de l'industrie le
musée des arts et métiers ce qui se vend
bien c'est qu'on peut juste les à paypal
est cité buzet sait plus quoi au nom
différent est la première marque affaire
c'est que si on devait prendre une
décision collective
une décision pour tous il y aura des
malheureux peut-être que peut-être que
monsieur préfère le palais a assité au
musée et peut-être qu'un autre préfère
le musée a assisté au palais et
peut-être que quelqu'un d'autre va voir
d'autres préférences a priori c'est un
on sera pas d'accord quoi il y aura il y
aura des malheureux quelle que soit la
décision que l'on prend pense que sa
première remarque importante affaire
sachant cela on danse et propose une
solution de moindre mal d'une certaine
manière nous dire que peut-être qu'on
peut pas rendre tout le monde heureux
mais peut-être que ce qu'on peut faire
c'est fait en sorte que la majorité des
gens soient pas trop malheureusement ça
c'est le principe de majorité
alors qu'elle que je dirais pas très
bien dit du coup on va laisser condorcet
le redire on appelle aujourd'hui le
principe des comores celle qui vit que
si une option est préféré à toute autre
option par une majorité alors à doit
être la décision collectif ça va pour
tout le monde
ces principes de majorité
et bien ce principe et violés par tous
les modèles par toutes les démocraties
du monde
très souvent en tout cas par exemple
s'ils feront l'élection présidentielle
française de 2012
il y avait ces cinq candidats au premier
n'avait plus ses cinq candidats entre
autres et au premier tour hollande et
sarkozy avaient le plus de votes du coup
ils sont passés au second tour et
hollande est devenue prison j'espère que
ça vous rappelle quelque chose et on
peut se demander du coup est-ce que
hollande était vraiment le candidat
préféré des français
en fait il ya des sondages qui montrent
que si on avait demandé en référendum le
soir même de l'élection si le peuple
préféré hollande ou béroud les sondages
montrent que béraud aurait gagné en
référendum
c'est assez bizarre parce que la france
vient d'élire un venait d'élire un
président qu'elle aurait préféré rejeter
au profit d'un autre candidat qu'elle
avait rejetée ça c'est bizarre en fait
le principe de condensat et violé le
principe de condorcet il aura fait élire
françois perrault c'est à dire que
beyrouth battait tous les autres
candidats en un contre un la majorité
préfère béraud à n'importe quel autre
candidat
alors je dis pas ça parce que je suis un
fan de bio ou pas du tout je suis un fan
de condorcet et du principe de commencer
et si on veut que le principe de
pauvreté soit appliquée c'est paulo
qu'il fallait dire la majorité du peuple
préféré bairon en fait le problème avec
les votes
la plupart des votes que l'on a c'est
qu'ils sont uninominaux ce n'est vous
lorsqu'on vote en fait on exprime notre
voix et lorsque on vote de façon in
hominal on dit pas grand chose à dire
les préférences des individus vont mes
préférences en tout cas les autres elles
sont beaucoup plus aux fissures
compliqué que quelques juste une option
fait ça c'est pas si on veut faire un
scrutin répondre c'est ce qu'il faut
c'est plus un classement eq ce prix
exprimé un classement entre les
différentes options
donc c'est ce que propose condorcet donc
je pense que vous avez votre téléphone
sur vous mais je vous propose de voter à
la contente c'est quand même classe que
versailles et à vue je suis en train de
faire voter des gens à la condenser vous
pouvez taper ça sur un nouveau téléphone
pour participer à cette élection est
donc à vous poser une question on va s'y
d'élire la plus grande réflexion de
condorcet donc j'ai limité vos choix
ces assises options et vous pouvez les
classer pour la france on va élire ce
qu'on pensait être la plus grande
réflexion de converser donc vous voyez
que cette solution de classement c'est
pas un truc de mathématiciens pure avec
l'action du juge c'est un truc est tout
à fait faisable en pratique donc ces
votations points au viage slash hashtag
votation slaj un des nains de 1,9
2/3 de 2,7 désolé de cette adresse url
donc le site votation ovh votation
prendre un virage qui a été lancé il ya
quelques mois et ils appliquent plus
coûteux comme orsay randomisés en
particulier on va parler
à ces classements une fois que chacun a
voté son classement ce qui est vraiment
cool c'est que on peut ensuite tracé ce
qu'on appelle un graphe des duels
c'est à dire qu'on est capable de savoir
quels sont les résultats de des duels
effet pour savoir présente si hollande
aurait battu sarkozy à partir de vos
votes
il suffit de regarder combien de
personnes ont mis hollande devant
sarkozy et combien de personnes ont mis
sarkozy devant hollande est donc avec
les votes par classement on est capable
de savoir tous les résultats des
référendums des un contre un entre les
différentes options
une fois j'ai mis une flèche de hollande
vers sarkozy parce que hollande on bat
serra battu sarkozy en duel en 2012
et avec ce graphe des duels on voit très
rapidement qui est vainqueur de
condorcet d'un car de quoi ressasser ce
qui va tout le monde en duel vainqueur
de lens est ici c'est clairement
françois bio puisque toutes les flèches
parle de lui vainqueur dr c'est un mec
dont tous les flèches enfin une option
non plus les flèches sortent donc si si
si je récapitule un petit peu tout
bêtement le scrutin est mort c'est bon
vote des classements par terré
classement notera sauvegarde des duels
et ensuite on élit le vainqueur de
condorcet tous à odense elle le savait
désolé leur dit non c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on n'a pas appliqué le projet
du scrutin à savoir 16 c'est
le cas suivant imaginons que parmi vous
en faites y ait un tiers d'anglais un
tiers de français et un tiers
d'américains
et que vous avez vous aviez les
préférences d'occupation on va essayer
de tracer le graphe des duels donc pour
tracer des duels font prendre à chaque
pas chaque paire donc on va essayer d'en
voir par exemple entre le palais et la
cité parce que le palais bas la cité
mais en fait on voit que les américains
et les anglais forment une majorité qui
dit que le palais est meilleur que la
cité deux classements à chaque fois le
palais bien avant la cité donc
maintenant si on garde entre la cité et
le musée bas là encore on allait enfin
là on a les français et les américains
et les anglais qui forment une majorité
qui dit que la cité est meilleur que le
musée et enfin la dernière flèche je
passe un peu vite balle et on a une
majorité qui américains et français qui
dit que le musée est meilleur que le
palais et là on a un problème parce que
dans ce grave des jo il n'y a pas de
vainqueur de coups mortels
non si tu n'as pas de deux options qui
bat toutes les autres duels on a un
cycle c'est ce qu'on appelle enfin c'est
ce que l'on appelle maintenant le
paradoxe de condorcet et ça aussi
condorcet le savait et pendant deux
siècles plus de deux siècles en gobain
les mathématiciens se sont dit bon bah
tant pis c'est pas quoi faire mais je
pense que c'est bon d'insister sur ça
mais ce paradoxe de condorcet c'est pas
juste un paradoxe de notre assassin
prennent la décision collective si on
veut une décision collective égalitaire
qui respecte le principe de condorcet
alors on va voir des cas où on ne sait
pas quoi faire on ne peut pas trancher
j'insiste pas mal sur ça parce que j'ai
une solution b
voilà la solution c'est utiliser ddc
utiliser le hasard il ya pas mal de
tours de la possibilité en théorie des
jeux en théorie des scrutins en fait le
hasard ça peut être une bonne solution
donc pour comprendre ce que j'entends
par le hasard en fait c'est que au lieu
de prendre une décision collective qui
va être une option
notre décision collective ça va être une
loi de probabilité c'est à dire à signer
des projets it et p1 p2 et p3
différentes options
ce qu'on appelle aussi une loterie en
fait on va élire ensemble non pas une
option mais une loterie
ensuite une fois que la loterie sera
choisi pour vraiment décidé on faire un
tirage au sort comme du chocolat
ce qui est cool avec les loteries c'est
qu'elles ont une jolie géométrie je vous
mettrai des loteries c'est enfin dans ce
cas c'est juste un triangle trois
options et intuitivement peut on est
proche du palais plus ça correspond à
une loterie qui a de grandes chances de
tirer le palais si on est exactement
tout au bol c'est la loterie qui tirent
tout le temps le palais je parle de
loterie de probabilité en fait c'est un
claude et des cas parfaitement
déterministe en voilà du team hm si on
est ici c'est une est loin du palais
donc ici il ya peu de probabilités pour
le palais et c'est quasiment une chance
sur deux pour les deux autres ont ce
qu'intuitivement ça ça s'entend bien
alors maintenant ce qu'on essaie de
faire c'est à baisser si d'appliquer le
principe de condorcet ou l'autriche et
pour ça faut que je définissent un objet
qui va être un truc qui va être la
préférence pour entre les loteries place
avec une définition un peu artificiel
mais j'espère qu'elle paraîtra naturel
on va dire que notre île a été préférée
à une autre ib c'est lorsque je tire
selon a et b ce que j'ai tiré selon as
est plus souvent meilleure que ce que
j'ai tiré selon b assez simple et non
phrase mais ça passe ça sonne bien
c'est pas trop choquant
voilà ça ça nous permet de savoir
comment tracer des flèches entre des
loteries donc je reprends mon triangle
avec toutes les loteries
maintenant faut imaginer qu'à plein de
flachau l'intérieur il ya des flèches
entre tout père de loterie les flames
dans tous les sens maintenant la grande
question c'est est ce que dans ce gr
font rares espèces de graff infinie est
ce que dans ce graphe des duels infinie
il y à un vainqueur de condorcet est ce
qu'il existe une loterie qui bat toutes
les autres en duel et bien la réponse
absolument merveilleuse c'est que la
réponse est non seulement oui il en
existe un mais en plus il en existe un
unique
ça c'est ce que j'appelle le théorème
fondamentale du scrutin de condorcet
randomisés c'est le fait qu' il existe
toujours dans une petite condition près
vous pouvez oublier ça pour aujourd'hui
il existe toujours un unique vainqueur
de condenser vraiment pratique lui sera
toujours en unis vainqueurs d'autres
mots c'est ça c'est un torrent de boue
pourtant ça commençait
ses intérêts mais incroyable quoi on
était bloqué par ce parce qu'ils
équipent lui avait pas il n'y avait pas
de vainqueur de caen c'est le principe
de comptoir ça ne s'appliquait pas la
citoyenneté
en fait si suffit de regarder ans la
probabilité est non seulement il
s'appliquera toujours mais marchera
toujours nickel qu il y aura toujours
une seule loterie a tiré ça c'est mon
plus beau théorème t on préfère des
mathématiques
je peux pas le prouver parce qu'il est
non tri gâté aussi ce qui fait c'est un
peu sa beauté c'est que bon je pouvais
sais pas non plus évident dans notre cas
où il y avait un paradoxe conversait le
vainqueur de marseille des loteries
c'est le point milieu donc le scrutin de
conversion domise est basse et j'ai tout
simplement suivre le principe de
condorcet généralisé aux loteries et il
marche tout le temps c'est ça qui est
beau alors ce scrutin il a de très
bonnes propriétés à part à part ça
notamment il est très robuste au 10ème
du vote utile
le dilemme du vote utile c'est quoi
c'est un bon bah mes préférences on ça
mais bon vaut mieux que je vote ça et ça
c'est assez gênant parce qu'au final
l'élection du coup se fait par rapport à
des à des voix qui sont pas vraiment ce
que le peuple a voulu dire du coup c'est
difficile de donner de la légitimité au
résultat est bien l'un des plus beaux
théorème un autre super théorème par
rapport aux scrutins précédents d'objets
c'est qu'il est robuste au 10ème du vote
utile bon il ya encore des petits
astérisques et petits caractères ce
serait sont un petit peu plus grave mais
ça va aussi
et puis un autre joli theoren c'est le
fait que si jamais on suppose qu'ils
aient une structure gauche droite dans
les camps les alternatives dans les
options donc ça c'est le cas typiquement
politique la gauche la droite est aussi
une structure souvent des préférences
des peuples par rapport à cette ligne
droite
si ça s'est vérifié alors il existe
toujours un vainqueur de condorcet des
options notre déterministe à ce moment
là le scrutin a commencé randomisés va
pas du tout et randomisés en fait il va
y lire le
vainqueur de condorcet déterministe
parce que s'il existe un vainqueur de
corse et déterministe alors c'est aussi
le vainqueur au torse et de l'autriche
du coup en fait la plupart du temps le
scrutin ont traversé randomisés n'est
pas randomisés s'assurer que ses coûts
et à ce moment là le scrutin de
condorcet et robuste au vote utile
coordonnées et encore plus robuste il
vraiment cru de tous toutes ces bonnes
pocket et le fait qu'il soit aussi
naturel que ce soit vraiment le principe
de condorcet généralisée et le fait
qu'ils soient robustes au 10ème du vote
utile me font dire aujourd'hui que c'est
vraiment le bon sens le temps
d'intervenir et que si une civilisation
extraterrestre à l'autre bout de la
galaxie qui est vraiment intelligente et
qui doit prendre des décisions
collectives parce qu'ils sont plusieurs
est qui qui pensent que le principe de
majorité est important je suis prêt à
parier que ces aliens utilisent les
scrutins de converser randomisés c'est
vraiment le scrutin de naturel
donc ce scrutin il est très appliqué
avant pratique hein c'est pas juste un
truc purement théorique donc je les
utilise et déjà plusieurs fois avec les
abonnés sur la chaîne youtube avec
thibault il utilise aussi de temps en
temps sur sa chaîne donc ça c'est un
scrutin qu'on a fait avec mes abonnés
avec 7000 personnes premiers scrutins
précédents de musée à grande échelle on
le dira et donc ceci de votation par ovh
vous ressort ingrate et doivent donc là
les flèches sont inversés en fait on se
fait que toutes les flèches pointe vers
ça ça veut dire que c'est moins
qu'annoncé en pointe de notation mais ça
s'est très très bien
et j'aimerais vous donner quelques
devoirs maisons qui sont pas des
exercices mais des vidéos à regarder
il ya beaucoup beaucoup plus à dire sur
cette théorie discutant c'est vraiment
une théorie fascinante donc notamment
par des vidéos de monsieur fille assure
le principe de confort ce qui explique
sa très très bien entendu pièces de
filles qu il ya cette superbe vidéo de
la statistique expliqué à mon chat qui
prend un cas particulier où il ya 55
candidats et il donne l'exemple de cinq
scrutins qui sont très naturels qui
pourraient se traîne très très normal et
il montre en fait que nos fins limiers
du pot que pour chaque candidat il
existe un scrutin qui élit ce candidat
qu'en fonction du scrutin que vous
utilisez vous élisez quelqu'un d'autre
ça pose vraiment la question de la
légitimité des personnes élues par les
scrutins parce que ça dépend des
scrutins c'est un peu embêtant c'est
pour ça que le principe de commencer est
important parce que ça permet de savoir
sur quelle danse place qu il ya aussi
cette superbe vidéo de sens étonnante
qui parle de de pas mal de choses en
théorie des scrutins en façon assez
générale comment du torrent d'armes
il parle aussi de l'alternative
aujourd'hui les camps d'alternative au
scrutin de converser rang de musique qui
est le jugement majoritaire qui a été
proposé c'est par des chercheurs
français michel bénech qui est rida
laraki qui est très bien mais voilà en
train de défendre condorcet donc je vais
pas dire que trop bien de la et enfin il
ya cette superbe vidéo qui parle de
comment il hier une assemblée qui en
fait un problème plus difficile parce
que il ya plus de l'assemblée c'est un
truc plus complexe que juste une option
du coup d'autres prennent un type qui se
pose est sage en vie aujourd'hui c'est
une question de recherche complètement
ouverte
je n'ai pas de réponse satisfaisante et
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de recherches
à faire encore dans ce domaine qui est
encore mal compris donc je vous remercie
pour cette présentation
merci d'avoir été là et puis je tiens
aussi à remercier surtout compenser pour
toutes ces contributions
merci
[Applaudissements]
comment est ce qu'on détermine s'est
assis ici une prise de décision
collective niveau fut inscrite en faux
regarde ce que tend donc c'est un peu
compliqué yaka pas ça c'est comme
trouver des fondements des mathématiques
pour partir quelque part
donc je pense qu'il faut il ya des
raisons de précieux en fait le jugement
majoritaire
il est par augusto 10ème du vote utile
il est assez robuste au dilemme du vote
utile mais il est pas robuste au dilemme
du vote utile coordonner ces incendies
gros problème et il ya d'autres
problèmes il est des trucs où ils sont
ils pas satisfaisant entièrement
philosophiquement je suis un peu biaisé
on y croit on choisit un restaurant ils
seront 20
soit totalement allergique au restaurant
à vomir cette image
par contre moi
très légère pour le restaurer
[Musique]
cette espèce dutil tourist
tout à fait c'est un poids trop
important a souligné jeudi que le
principe de condorcet est l'un des
principes les plus beaux de la théorie
des scrutins en fait il un autre
principe qui est peut-être qui est très
connu qui est du tourisme qui est
maximisée la somme du bonheur et c'est
incompatible avec 25 des cas où c'est
incompatible en l'état avec le principe
de converser le prennent souvent en fait
de deux de l'utilitarisme dans ce cas
c'est que prendre une décision
collective avec l'égalité et robustesse
au deuxième du vote utile c'est s'est
confié qu elle est en gros
l'utilitarisme est le dilemme du vote
utile se combine très très mal
mathématiquement donc c'est un peu
difficile d'avoir une solution qui
combinait de quoi mais dans d'autres cas
particulier je pense qu'il vaut mieux
partir avec le terrorisme que avec le
principe de prudence et si on avons
plusieurs décisions
plusieurs décisions les gens
mettez beaucoup d'importance ouais en
fait l'une des difficultés qui peuvent
apparaître
parce qu'en fait là je prends vraiment
des cas où le nombre d'options est très
petit et en fait pendant si je pense à
une assemblée déjà le nombre d'apps
d'assemblée qu'il peut y avoir
pendant que ça chaque chaque
représentant est en fait quelqu'un de
différent expliqué en pratique en fait
là on a une exposition une explosion
combinatoire et du coup le on peut pas
appliquer ce qu'on est en train de
converser en domise et et s'est même pas
forcément souhaitable souvent il ya des
structures en plus dans les préférences
des gens et en fait il faut il faut
essayer d'exploiter les structures que
l'on peut trouver dans les préférences
des gens pour essayer de concevoir ses
passions et utilitariste notamment
d'avoir quelque chose qui n'existe plus
la somme des utilités en exploitant les
propriétés des préférences des gens que
typiquement je pense propriété des
préférences des gens et par exemple les
gens préfèrent fins monotone par rapport
à l'argent typiquement plus d'argent
c'est mieux ça c'est genre le genre de
propriété qui peut être exploité dormir
toute la théorie des enchères pour
pouvoir prendre des décisions qui sont
plus utilitariste et puis puis en fait
il ya d'autres propriétaires je voulais
signaler on a parlé du titteri il ya un
autre problème ce qui est l'équité de
touché par le fait de ne pas avoir de
billets qui sont des trucs qui
n'apparaissent pas dans le principe de
conseil qui n'apparaissent pas dans
utilitarisme en tout cas de base et du
coup voilà il faut peut-être encore une
autre fonction objectif un autre
objectif de société en fait ces finales
savent rien vraiment à ça et c'est une
question qui est en fait extrêmement
difficile
je veux pas insister suffisamment sur la
difficulté de décrire une fonction
d'objectifs pour nos sociétés on sera
tous des gens sympas tous d'accord et en
plus il faut combiner tout ça et je
pense que même individuellement pour
chacun d'entre eux ne s'est pas évident
de dire ce qu'on veut de la société soit
voilà et je pense que justement la
mathématisation de ça peut aider en
partie alors il devra tout pas tout le
problème mais ça peut aider à structurer
la pensée va tout simplement parce
qu'ils tout nouveau une certaine manière
donc et où il ya une kia le théorème
fondamentale d'inquiéter pendant 93 mais
dans un format très différents et les
gens n'ont pas vu que ça revenait à dire
que le principe de condorcet se
généraliser très bien aux loteries donc
ça ça elle a fait pas mal de temps
par exemple il ya à dire que c'est moi
qui ai inventé moi j'ai pas mal
contribué à faire en sorte que
d'interpréter ce taux est fondamental
dans le cadre du scrutin dans ses rangs
de musées et de cesser de dire vraiment
c'est le principe de condorcet donc
c'est encore tout récent vous parle par
exemple le site de sites qu'elle vous a
envoyé votation pas en cash c'est le
premier endroit que je connaisse ou où
on peut voter un scrutin a commencé en
explique lui qu'il est indépendant
[Musique]
est-ce que ça ça me mettrait deux
que c'est
le fossé qui s'était plus en plus entre
la
la gauche dans la sélection entre les
différents groupes que ce soit en jouant
eux
c'est une très bonne question parce que
ça peut poser une question sur un très
long terme que j'ai pas utilisé
aujourd'hui l'indépendance va tellement
pertinente mais en effet le scrutin de
converser et indépendant aux
alternatives non pertinentes qui est une
bd très très très belle propriété
j'ai pas mentionner c'est à dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui en fait de lui
en fait aux élections de 2002 par
exemple en france il y avait en gros
deux grands candidats jospin et chirac
est en fait justement et s'est fait
sortir au premier tour parce qu'elle
avait beaucoup de candidats de gauche et
beaucoup d'électeurs de gauche qui ont
voté pour ces autres candidats de gauche
qu'en fait la présence des autres
candidats de gauche a nui aux grands
candidats de gauche
quand en toi je dis pas ça pour défendre
la gauche molle mais il faut bien voir
que du coup il ya un intérêt de la part
de chaque partie de limiter le nombre de
ses candidats et le cas extrême de ça
ces états unis aux états unis il ya deux
candidats pas plus en groupe
s'il y en a plus mais en pratique les
deux candidats quoi et ça c'est une
conséquence du scrutin c'est pas une
conséquence enfin on peut assez voire
assassinés est clairement comme une
conséquence de ce côté c'est à dire que
dans un scrutin qui dépendant aux
interdits venons père tenant bien non
pertinentes
les politiques vont avoir intérêt à se
structurer en fonction de cette
dépendance aux alternatives non
pertinentes et du coup ça va
dans le cas des états unis ça conduit
vraiment à ce bi polaris mas et ses deux
gros partis qui s'affrontent et c'est
vraiment une conséquence de scrutin
s'est choisi changer de scrutin c'est
indispensable si on veut mettre fin ce
bipolarisme qui as est extrêmement qu'en
france c'est moins le cas à ce point
mais ça reste ce que tu as deux yeux à
ce mot à deux tours est un peu moins
victime de ça mais il ya encore pas mal
comme le cas de 2002 le montre et
enfin c'est parce que du coup sûr est
que se présenter en tant que candidat
c'est un énorme dilemme pour chacun que
si on se représente donc je crois je
prends souvent l'exemple de imaginant
que bernie sanders qui était l'autre
deux grands candidats démocrates aux
élections présidentielles de 2016 se
présente à ce moment ils avaient volé
des voix à hillary clinton qui était le
candidat qui lui ressemblait le plus et
du coup ce le fait de se présenter nui à
sa cause
c'est pas satisfaisant quand propriété
et donc l'indépendance aux alternatives
non pertinente c'est à dire que c'est
pas le cas c'est à chaque fois que
quelqu'un se présente il peut pas nuire
ou favoriser la cause d'un autre
candidat et c'est une propriété qu'elle
se satisfait le scrutin a commencé en
devises et le jugement majoritaire aussi
d'ailleurs des métiers et comme on dit
prenons le cas du nantais au minck à
l'autre et si on compare cette le prix
par exemple qu'il choisit toujours
j'ai l'impression dans un tir des cas de
loterie faut donner la même chose dans
un tiers notre rihanna thouars
je vous ai menti encore dans cette
présentation
en fait je mets une flèche d'une
auterive vers l'autre si l'autre ne l'a
pas par ses qualités je mets quand même
la flèche donc ces petits détails
techniques en effet mais le problème en
fait si on y lit le palais c'est que
après le palais perd contre quelqu'un
d'autre en duel du coup en fait la
propriété fondamentale du vainqueur de
condorcet des loteries c'est qu' il n'y
a aucune alternative qui est strictement
meilleure qu'elle suivait très gros
c'est ça lui aurait dû dire et c'est la
seule à vérifier cette propriété pour
conclure cette vidéo j'aimerais vraiment
remercier tous ceux qui ont rendu cet
événement possible pour eux c'était
vraiment un moment fantastique donc
vraiment merci merci beaucoup à tous les
organisateurs merci à l'institut henri
poincaré merci au centre des monuments
nationaux
merci roger mansuy merci edouard bruno
et merci à tous ceux qui sont venus
assister à la conférence mais également
à tous ceux qui vous qui me suivait sur
sur scène florale c'est un peu grâce à
vous que finalement j'ai la chance
d'être invité à de tels événements merci
merci de me suivre
merci